first then once that's over we'll get
some thoughts from you thanks
the senators seemed unimpressed perhaps
it was because they already knew too
much each senator arriving with a fat
orange colored notebook crammed with
classified material about the cia
all marked top secret
after five months of closed-door
investigation of talking in private with
intelligence agents and officials most
of the senators now agree with chairman
frank church that the cia has indeed
been a rogue elephant out of control
so the testimony of colby didn't allay
the suspicions
the hearings took place in the historic
senate caucus room scene of the dramatic
watergate investigation just two years
ago
the press was back in great numbers
today but not the public
there were in fact no long lines and the
seats reserved for the audience were at
times only two-thirds filled
as someone said after what has happened
in this country during the past two
years there are no more future shocks
but whether there are shocks or not
today's open hearing did focus major
attention on the way the cia has gone
about its business in the united states
subject today concerns cia's involvement
in the development of bacteriological
warfare materials with the army's
biological laboratory at fort dietrich
cia's retention of a num of an amount of
shellfish toxin and cia's use and
investigation of various chemicals and
drugs
the relationship between the cia and the
army biological laboratory at fort
dietrich as an activity requiring
further investigation surfaced in late
april of this year
it resulted from information provided by
a ca cia officer not directly associated
with the project in response to my
repeated directives that all past
activities which might now be considered
questionable be brought to the attention
of agency management
information provided by him and by two
other officers aware of the project
indicated that the project at port
dietrich involved the development of
bacteriological warfare agents some
lethal
and associated delivery systems suitable
for clandestine use
a search was made for any records or
other information available on the
project
this search produced information about
the basic agreement between the army and
the cia relating to the project and some
limited records
covering its activities from its
beginning in 1952 to its termination in
1970.
in the course of the investigation cia's
laboratory storage facilities were
searched and about 11 grams a little
less than half an ounce of shellfish
toxin and eight milligrams of cobra
venom were discovered in a little used
vaulted store room in an agency building
a major early requirement of the agency
was to find a replacement for the
standard cyanide l pill issued to agents
in hazardous situations during world war
ii
this was the basis on which eventually
we discovered the
shellfish toxin
the only application of this toxin was
in the u2 flight over the ussr in may
1960
during which gary powers carried such a
device concealed in a silver dollar
in the powers case the grooves of the of
the
the drill were filled with shellfish
toxin he obviously did not use it and
was not instructed to do so it was
offered to him to provide him with an
option
the powers flight was the only time we
are aware that the toxin was provided
for operational use
although the l pill was made available
for earlier flights
the primary agency interest was in the
development of dissemination devices to
be used with standard chemicals off the
cell shell
various dissemination devices such as a
fountain pen dart launcher and an engine
head bolt designed to release when heat
appeared to be peculiarly suited for
agent for clandestine use
available records do not indicate that
all specific items were developed
exclusively for the cia as work on
similar devices was also done for the
army
at the time the toxin was found the
officer responsible for the project in
1970 stated that he had no recollection
as to how it got there
on the 30th of june discussions were
held with a retired agency officer who
had provided the initial lead
this man who had been the gs 15 branch
chief in 1970 stated that the toxin had
in fact been moved from fort detrick and
stored in the laboratory
this was done on the basis of his own
decision after conversations with the
responsible project officer he further
stated that he made this decision based
on the fact that the cost and difficulty
of isolating the shellfish toxin were so
great that it simply made no sense to
destroy it particularly when there would
be no future source of such toxins
the current branch chief believes this
explanation is correct but still does
not recall the actual act of receiving
the material from fort detrick
both of these middle grade officers
agree that no no one including their
immediate superior
was told of the retention of the
shellfish toxin
if
that amount of shellfish toxin were
administered orally
which is one of
the least efficient ways for
administering it
in terms of its lethality
that quantity was sufficient to kill at
least
14 000 people
if it were administered with the
sophisticated uh
equipment that was found in the
laboratory
that quantity would be sufficient to
kill a great many more
[Music]
estimates vary upwards into the hundreds
of thousands
now
my first question is why
did the agency
prepare
a shellfish toxin
for which there is no practical antidote
which attacks the
nervous system and brings on
death very quickly
why did the agency prepare toxins
of this character
in quantities
sufficient to kill
many thousands of people what was the
need for that in the first place long
before the presidential order came down
to destroy this material
i think the uh the first uh part of the
answer to that question mr chairman is
the
the fact that the l pill which was
developed and during world war ii does
take some time to work and is
particularly agonizing to the subject
who uses it
uh the
some of the people who would be natural
uh requesters of such a capability for
their own protection and the protection
of their fellow agents
really would not want to face that kind
of a fate
but if they could be given an
instantaneous one they would uh accept
that and that was the thought process
behind developing the capability now i
cannot uh explain why
that quantity was developed except that
this was a collaboration that we were
engaged in with the united states army
and we did develop this particular
weapon you might say as a possible uh
for possible use now when cia retained
the amount that it did it obviously did
it improperly
this quantity
and the
various devices
for
administering the toxins that were found
in the laboratory
certainly
make it clear that
purely defensive uses were not
what the agency
uh had had was limited to in any way
there were definite offensive uses in
fact there were dart guns you mentioned
suicides
well i i don't think a
suicide is usually accomplished with a
dart
particularly a gun that can
can
place the dart in a human target in such
a way that he doesn't even know that
he's been hit
there's no question about it it was also
for offensive reasons no question have
you brought with you
[Music]
some of those devices which would have
enabled the cia to use this poison for
we have indeed for killing
people
[Music]
don't point it at me
i wonder
[Music]
now
does does this
does this
pistol uh fire the dart yes it does mr
chairman the uh that the round thing at
the top is obviously the sight
the rest of it is uh what is practically
a uh a normal 45 although it's it's
special
it however it works by electricity
there's a battery in the handle and it
fires a small door so that when it fires
it fires silently
almost silently yes
very little what range does it have
100 meters i believe about about 100
yards 100 meters about a hundred meters
right
and the dart itself when it strikes the
the target
um
does the uh target know that he's about
he's been hit and about to die that
depends mr chairman on the particular
dart use there are different kinds of
these fleshettes that were used in in
various weapons system and a special one
was developed which
potentially would be able to enter the
target without perception
without perception right
and did you find such such darts in the
library in the laboratory we did
yes
isn't it true too that
the the effort
not only involved
designing a gun that could
[Music]
strike a human target
without knowledge of the person who'd
been struck
but also the toxin itself would not
appear in the autopsy
well there was an attempt for the dark
yes so that uh there was no no way of
perceiving that the uh the target was
hit
as a murder instrument that's about as
efficient as you can get isn't it
it it is a weapon a very serious weapon
this record seems to disclose an
additional concession namely uh the lack
of accountability
so that we not only have a secret agency
but we have an agency which about which
there's some question as to its
accountability
to the authority of the president or to
the authority of the national security
council
the record seems to disclose
that there is no
presidential or security council order
in the first place
directing the
cia to establish this program at all
secondly there appears to be no report
by the cia to hire authority
of the existence of these toxins or
biological weapons
thirdly there seems to be no evidence
that those in charge of the cia
inquired of subordinates
as to the existence of toxins or
biological weapons
or that following the presidential order
decreeing the destruction of such toxins
that any formal order went forth within
the cia
to require their destruction
moreover the record seems to
support the notion
that it was only by chance
that the leadership of the cia became
aware some years later of even the
existence
of these
lethal toxins which were in violation of
a direct
presidential order in short the record's
a mess
and we may never know
just exactly what happened
no one has interviewed gottlieb as to
why he destroyed the material or what
they protect the record no i i we have
not interviewed him to the reason you
know what
what documents he destroyed
we're very unsure as to the total we do
not have an inventory of do you think
they might have said who it was
authorized the
formulation or the retention of this
stuff do you have any reason to think it
might or might not contain that
information
in this case i i doubt that it would
have very much because this uh case
indicate from the evidence we have at
hand does it say anything have any
reason to think that it might say how if
at all this material was used in an
aggressive way against someone to kill
someone well there may well be some of
that
in in the when was the when was the
documentation destroyed
in
1973 and it didn't happen to be
destroyed at the same time those tapes
1972 1972 1972 when in 1917 in november
i believe it was in november of 72.
do you have any idea what volume of
records were destroyed
i do not know you know who authorized
the destruction if anyone as i said
there was a memorandum of agreement
between the the uh director and and mr
gottlieb at that time and the director
at that time was mr hounds mr helms is
here in this room i believe mr chairman
and i take it we'll have an opportunity
to hear from him
will be our witness uh tomorrow
morning's hearings i believe he's the
lead off witness
uh
i won't prolong my
opportunity to examine the witness much
longer mr chairman i understand we're
going to try to operate under the
10-minute rule may i ask you only this
other question then in general mr colby
you've heard of the doctrine of
plausible deniability yes and i've
rejected it uh now senator i say that uh
we cannot depend upon that anymore the
question i was going to put to you is
that a phrase of art in the intelligence
community does it have a separate
significance that you understand it was
a rationale used in earlier years
if the united states could deny
something and
not be
clearly demonstrated as a as having
said something falsely then the united
states could do so in the case of
assassinations in the case of
any other of domestic surveillance in
the case of the formulation of poisons
under that previous rationale
would the doctrine of plausible
deniability have led the agency to
destroy records to conceal evidence or
to compartmentalize to the point where
it would be un
a committee such as this later would
have been unable to establish what
really happened i think the plausible
denial concept was used in in the sense
of international diplomatic
relationships that are you saying by
that that it would not have applied to
the formulation of toxic materials i
would not say that it didn't have
anything to do with it at all but i
think that the basic rationale for the
doctrine of plausible denial was so that
our nation could deny something and not
be uh and not be tagged with
colby can you be absolutely sure that
there aren't other vaults containing
poison somewhere in this town or in this
country or
in our possession some in some part of
the world
i can't be absolutely sure no senator i
we obviously are conducting such
investigations and have issued such
orders as possible but i cannot be
absolutely sure that some
officer somewhere has not sequestered
something
could you as concisely as possible state
for the committee your understanding of
the practice of compartmentation
well the compartmentation
practice is merely the the strict
application of the need to know
principle
if
an employee in the intelligence business
needs to know something in order to do
his job
then he has a right to the information
but if he does not need to know that
particular information he does not have
a right to to the information and uh
if the information is one which is which
is required for large numbers of
employees then large numbers of
employees will be allowed to know it if
the if the particular activity is a very
sensitive matter and only a very few
employees need to know it then it will
be known to only a very few employees we
make a particular effort
to keep the identity identities of our
sources and some of our more
complicated technical systems restricted
very sharply in the in the to the people
who actually need to work on them and
many of the rest of the people in the
agency know nothing about them does that
need to know principle apply in cases of
sensitivity to the director of central
intelligence certainly not it does not
with one exception
i do not believe i need to know the name
of an agent in some foreign country
who's serving us at the risk of his life
i know he's there i know what kind of a
person he is but i do not know to need
to know his actual name and i have kept
that out of my my knowledge because i
travel and i don't want to know
that kind of a thing but that's the only
area that i would apply it to i i am
responsible for everything that happens
in the agency i need to know everything
that happens in the agency
we've spoken
rather extensively here about
apparent lack of clear lines of control
and authority running downward in
elementary clear lines of responsibility
and accountability running upward
to the best of your knowledge
[Music]
has there been any
pervasive
non-compliance
in the matter of orders from directed to
the president or orders from
the dci
on the part of subordinates
in other words has this uh
reached a greater proportion than might
even have uh been revealed here
as a result of our discovery of
a very
i think significant
instance of
insubordination if indeed
it has been pervasive isn't there need
for
much tighter controls
at the top
senator tower i believe that
we are
really we have ncia a very tight
discipline i'm not saying it's total
obviously it did not work in this case
but i think with the
people scattered around the world doing
very sensitive work doing highly
compartmented work uh there has been
indeed a very high sense of discipline
in the organization and a high sense of
compliance to the the regulations and
the rules and the directives of the
organization and i think that the
leadership of the organization has
always felt very much subject to direct
presidential control and uh responsive
to it
so you would say actually that this
incident uh is an exception to the rule
that ordinarily the discipline has been
good that the
that the control
has worked and the accountability has
worked in the way that it should
according to
proper cardinals of good administration
in the uh in the
business in which we are in the
intelligence and covert operations i
think there have been very few
cases in which the agency has or its
employees have done something that they
should not have and in many of the cases
which we now question
we find that that those activities were
approved by the
by the appropriate authorities at that
time that the sense of discipline within
the organization seemed to be quite
tight
senator goldwater
thank you mr chairman i only have one
question mr colby but i have a short
statement i'd like to make to you
criticism and analysis are important
ingredients in making our democracy work
however we are now approaching the point
where both are being abused to the point
of self-destruction
i submit we must get out of the morass
of doubt and pessimism into which we
have sunk
we must not let the quarrels of the past
interfere with building for the future
a tidal wave of criticism has swept over
the intelligence community of our
country much of which is mistaken or
unwarranted
the damage is severe
if continued its survival is uncertain
before this committee have appeared men
of the cia both on active duty and
retired
all have been impressive because of the
dedication and loyalty
nothing we have heard detracts from the
reputation of the cia as a highly
competent organization
the men and women of the cia are doing a
great job under very trying conditions
and i say to them as our nation gets
back on course
i i believe there will be change for the
better and ask you to hold on until that
happens
you are never more needed by this
country than right now
and as one american i'm proud of you
to those young people who may be looking
for careers and who have a desire for
public service
i can think of no better way to serve
your nation than as an intelligence
officer
many skills are required to keep the cia
a useful and productive organization
continuity is vital to america now mr
coby
senator goldwater if i may on behalf of
our employees thank you for that
statement they are under a lot of
pressure these days and they will
appreciate that
well the question i have to ask you
have other countries develop
bacterial warfare ability oh certainly
uh senator we that is one aspect of
bacteriological warfare that uh the
president's directive in 1969 and 70
tells cia to continue and that is to
follow the activities of other nations
that we will
see the capabilities and activities of
other nations in this field
and we have some officers who do follow
this uh
these activities abroad and uh they are
quite uh quite general there are some
very
very dubious areas where we're just not
sure of what the actual capabilities are
in some respects but we do follow it
indeed and there is extensive effort
done by by other nations in this line
that you are now prevented
from
no we can follow the foreign ones there
is no problem but can you do anything to
offset them
well i think the defense uh the
defensive against those possible things
is a matter for the department of
defense senator
you feel you're safe in that field well
i think in collaboration with the
department of defense and advising the
department of defense of foreign
developments in this area
we are giving them the basis for
developing such defensive efforts as we
need thank you that's all i have mr
chairman thank you senator goldbar
senator morgan
mr chairman
mr kobe
since this is the first public hearing
of this committee i think we should note
that
we feel and i certainly feel that the
role played by the central intelligence
agency is a very vital one
and a very important one
i think the fact that you quoted from
president kennedy who said that quite
often our
failures are trumpeted
and our success is going hurled it is
appropriate here
this committee has been told by
witnesses that had the central
intelligence agency existed prior to
world war ii
pearl harbor might never have happened
or if it had happened
the loss of in deaths
and property might have been much less
so i want you to know that we do
recognize the role of the central
intelligence agency
we recognize the fact that we in this
country must be able to
know in advance
what our potential adversaries and
potential enemies
may be planting so that we can cope with
them
so i do think that that it is important
i believe mr kobe most of the questions
have been asked
except that earlier the reference
reference was made to the presidential
order
and we alluded to what was in fact i
think the press release
concerning the presidential order
but as i read the presidential order
i find that the united this state
united states bacteriological and
biological programs will be confined to
research and development
for defensive purposes immunization
safety measures etc
this does not preclude research into
those offensive aspects
of bacteriological biological agents
necessary to determine
what defensive measures are required
now earlier you stated you thought it
might have been the mentality of those
who made the decision to keep these
toxins
that they might be needed in order to
develop defensive weapons
do you think if that was their thinking
that it would be in keeping with the
presidential orders i just read it to
you well we looked at that i think that
you might be able to make a case for
that
senator if you were uh actively involved
and had responsibilities for these
defensive measures but as i think the
chairman pointed out the quantities
of maintained by cia
are difficult to defend under that
direction what was your position with
the cia at that time mr
in 1970 i was on on detached service i
was
i was assigned to the department of
state in vietnam then you had nothing to
do with retaining these toxins no i had
nothing and you knew nothing about them
until you made the
until we discovered it this uh in in may
i uh i would commend you
mr kobe again for taking these steps to
determine what has happened
i think most
men in the cia as well as those in the
internal revenue service
and the federal bureau of investigation
are dedicated public officials and want
to do what is right
and i think your method of asking for
any known violations has been helpful to
this committee
and i would commend it mr chairman to
the
internal revenue service
to the end that they might ask their
field agents if they know or known
violations
in this area and i would commend it also
to the director of the federal bureau of
investigation
senator goldwater
mentioned and i believe the presidential
order directed the cia to continue to
maintain surveillance surveillance
of the bacteriological and biological
warfare capabilities of other states
you say you have done that we do so yes
sir are you in a position to tell this
committee whether or not other states
and especially potential adversaries or
enemies now have stockpiles of such
toxins
i don't think i can say much about
stockpiles but i do know that there are
installations which appear to us to be
uh experimental stations of some sort
thank you
uh with the in the chemical field uh
certainly there are stockpiles we are
aware of that also
[Applause]
thank you senator senator matthias
thank you mr chairman
mr
colby
some of america's greatest victories
and some of america's greatest defeats
have represented failures of
intelligence
trenton and antietam
pearl harbor
i think all illustrate uh
the vital necessity
of intelligence
a year ago just almost exactly a year
ago when senator mansfield and i
introduced the legislation which has
resulted
in this investigation we had that very
much in mind we wanted to be sure that
we had the best intelligence
system
which was available
but i think we also had in mind john
adams warning
that a frequent recurrence to the
principles of the constitution
is absolutely necessary to preserve the
advantages of liberty
and to maintain a free government
i think the
discovery of this toxin
raises
some interesting questions
which are within the purview of this
investigation and which i think
have to be answered
before this committee completes its work
and makes its recommendations to the
congress
for example
i
accept your statement that this toxin
was never used
except in the one
instance that you've described
but i
then have to ask you this if you had
used the toxin
what provision of the constitution
would have afforded
authority to do so
well i think uh cia's operations are
certainly overseas operations they fall
under the national security act
of 1947
and they fall consequently under the
provisions of the constitution that call
for the the national defense and the
foreign relations of the united states
but the use of a toxin of this sort is
of course a use of force wouldn't you
agree it's a weapon it's a west it's a
use of force
and
normally if force is to be employed
against another nation
congressional approval is
required isn't that true well i think
we're now uh in the midst of the war
powers act uh senator and uh
this uh activity of course preceded that
yes it did
precede it
but what occurs to me here is that we
have an illustration
of the use of force
in the relations of the united states
with other powers in the world
or at least the potential use of force
as you say it's never been used in this
instance
which differs only in degree
from
covert operations in laos
or
other examples that we could think of
and so it seems to me that the discovery
of this toxin
raises very fundamental questions about
the
relationship to the covert activities of
any intelligence agency be it the cia or
the fbi or others
with the constitutional process by which
this government
is conducted
and i would think mr chairman that there
is
no responsibility greater upon us
than to define that relationship
as accurately as possible before the
close of these hearings thank you it is
of course uh
contained within the amendment to the
foreign assistant act passed last
december which
now requires that any activity of cia
other than intelligence gathering abroad
shall be
found to be important to the national
security by the president and shall be
reported to the appropriate committees
and that includes six committees of the
congress at this time this is a
statutory provision which we are in
compliance with and and let me say mr
colby i i agree with you let me say that
this imposes responsibilities on the
congress that i don't think we've always
discharged very well
i i can recall
members of congress who
recoiled
from
responsibility of knowing what was
happening members of congress who said
don't tell me i don't want to know
i think
that is an indictment of the congress
just as severe as any indictment which
is labeled
against any of the intelligence
community i wouldn't call it an
indictment of the congress senator i
think it rather reflected the general
atmosphere and political atmosphere
toward intelligence that uh that was the
traditional approach and i think we
americans are changing that and
this this act is a is an example of that
change as is this committee i think
you're more uh
generous and i'm inclined to be i can't
be that permissive i don't think climate
will excuse what is really at their
election and duty and if there had not
been that dereliction of duty perhaps we
wouldn't be here today
i must say senator matthias that i agree
fully that
we have been victimized by excessive
secrecy
not only with respect to the failure of
the congress and the past exercise
proper surveillance over intelligence
activities
but also
excessive secrecy has created this kind
of mischief within the executive branch
here we have a case
where the very
methods of secrecy
uh concealed for five years
an act of insubordination within the cia
that
came to light only by the happenstance
but mr colby the present director asked
the agency if they please wouldn't tell
him
what's been going on that's wrong
and as a result somebody
knowing something about this
gave him a tip
as a result of which he then conducted
an investigation that led to these disco
this disclosure so i believe that the
internal
uh workings
uh within the agency itself are
a matter that we must look at very
closely to be sure that this kind of
thing doesn't happen again if it can be
prevented
excessive secrecy may have victimized
this agency as well as the congress
the senate